[Música]
buenas noches hoy alan austria y les doy
la bienvenida a este especial de france
24 sobre el plebiscito constitucional en
chile una jornada histórica en la que
los ciudadanos acudieron a las urnas
para decidir el futuro de la
constitución que data de 1980 cuando el
poder estaba en manos de augusto
pinochet a lo largo de este especial
vamos a revisar los resultados con
nuestra corresponsal en santiago
patricia luna ya analizar la información
con nuestras invitadas elisa walker
abogada magíster en derecho y filosofía
y sandra ponce de léon abogada magíster
en derecho público con mención en
derecho constitucional por la
universidad católica de chile muy
bienvenidas a todas se pronostica que la
participación de este domingo será la
más alta desde que se instauró el voto
voluntario en 2012 los ciudadanos debían
responder dos preguntas pregunta uno
quiere usted una nueva constitución y
debían seleccionar entre las opciones
aprueba y rechazó mientras que la
pregunta 2
y órgano debería redactar esta nueva
constitución convención mixta o
convención constitucional la comisión
mixta está compuesta por 172 miembros
distribuida en partes iguales entre
ciudadanos electos y parlamentarios y la
convención constitucional de 155
miembros en la cual todos sus
integrantes tienen que ser elegidos
específicamente para este propósito
ampliaremos sobre este tema el tipo de
órgano constitucional más adelante con
nuestras especialistas primero veamos
cómo van los resultados
al momento son
53 punto 95 por ciento de mesas
escrutadas con un 77 90 por ciento de
apruebo 22 10 por ciento de rechazo
mientras que en una constitución mixta
el tipo de órgano 2102 la convención
constitucional 78 98 por ciento
[Música]
vamos estar actualizando los resultados
cada 10 minutos durante este especial y
es que este plebiscito del domingo se
produjo en respuesta a las masivas
manifestaciones de 2019 por la igualdad
social la cita electoral había sido
pactada para abril pero fue aplazada por
la pandemia del cob y 19 el reclamó
inicio por el aumento del precio del
pasaje de transporte público pero derivó
en un reclamo por cambios de fondo en
las políticas gubernamentales que han
profundizado la desigualdad
[Música]
una constitución nunca parte de cero
porque representa el encuentro de las
generaciones una constitución siempre
debe recoger la herencia de las
generaciones que nos antecedieron la
libertad y voluntad de las generaciones
presentes y la esperanza de las
generaciones que vendrán para que este
proceso constituyente logre sus
objetivos y dé frutos
segundos todos los hombres y mujeres de
buena voluntad debemos entregar lo mejor
de nosotros mismos abrir nuestros
espíritus al diálogo practicar el
respeto y la tolerancia tener voluntad
de acuerdos y rechazar la violencia este
es el mensaje que hace unos momentos dio
a la nación el presidente sebastián
piñera momento de revisar cuáles son los
principales puntos polémicos de esta
constitución que precisamente durante
las protestas de 2019 fue señalada por
algunos chilenos como fuente de
desigualdad aseguran que deja en manos
privadas numerosos derechos
fundamentales que no son garantizados
por el estado veamos este informe de
valentina datos recientes
la constitución de 1980 establece que en
chile el agua es privada lo que no
ocurre en ningún otro país del mundo
los chilenos pagan una de las tarifas
más altas de américa latina' para
consumir agua potable que en su gran
mayoría es propiedad de empresas
transnacionales
[Música]
lo mismo ocurre con los recursos
minerales la constitución permite que
compañías privadas extranjeras extraigan
los bienes naturales que son un pilar de
la economía del país como el litio y el
cobre pero sin contemplar la
participación de industrias nacionales
ni del estado
[Música]
la carta magna también habla del estado
subsidiario lo que significa que el
estado vigila a los particulares que
prestan los servicios de salud educación
o seguridad social pero no provee
directamente las prestaciones para que
los ciudadanos accedan a ellos los
servicios públicos de salud educación y
pensiones son calificados de precarios
en el país
[Música]
en la constitución está determinado que
cualquier modificación debe contar con
el apoyo de dos tercios de los
legisladores tanto del senado como de la
cámara lo que hace que los cambios sean
muy difíciles de aprobar
gran parte de la población chilena
asegura que es ilegítimo tener una
constitución heredada de la dictadura
por lo que defiende la propuesta de hoja
en blanco que contempla el reemplazo de
la carta magna
enlazamos con patricia luna corresponsal
de france 24 en santiago patricia te
escuchamos vía telefónica qué datos
tienes al momento sobre los incidentes
que ha dejado la jornada y de votos en
el extranjero
bueno pues por el momento lo que estamos
viviendo en este momento es una masiva
gran celebración que se extiende por
todo el país es un momento muy esperado
por los chilenos diríamos que son
décadas esperando este momento estamos
en las inmediaciones de plaza italia
donde se ha reunido muchísima gente por
el momento el tono es más bien pacífico
hay banderazos hay cláxones de automóvil
hay mucho ambiente y gente que no deja
de llegar a familias niños gente joven
sobre todo que se reúne en un ambiente
va a ser en festivo en este momento en
la zona donde nosotros estamos les está
todo bastante pacífico sabemos que estas
celebraciones se están repitiendo a lo
largo de todo el país no solo en
santiago en otros puntos de santiago no
solo en plaza italia también en el norte
del país en las topadas acá veíamos
grandes manifestaciones y esta zona por
el momento el voto en el extranjero
también ha mostrado una tendencia
similar a la de
a los resultados que habéis ofrecido
donde la prueba se han puesto con una
importante mayoría por el momento
patricia nos dice es que es un ambiente
de festejo pero también se reportaron
algunos incidentes de posibles bloqueos
de manifestantes en la plaza principal
de la capital de santiago
así es el principio de la tarde se
bloqueó el tráfico en esta zona que es
céntrica de la capital es un punto
neurálgico pero a partir de ahí empezó a
llegar muchísima más gente y el tráfico
es el río como suele ser habitual cuando
corre en este tipo de celebraciones la
cantidad de gente ahora mismo en plaza
italia es bastante bastante masiva
similar a lo que hemos visto otros otros
momentos en imágenes sigue llegando
gente a el momento que hablamos sigue
pasando gente con la bandera mapuche
desde que festeja como podéis escuchar
sí que hubo incidentes al comienzo de la
tarde pero en este momento en el lugar
donde nosotros estamos todo es pacífico
es celebración es luces artificiales es
el claxon es gente cantando
como podéis verlo el pueblo el pueblo
dónde está
a la calle exigiendo dignidad eso es lo
que pasa la gente que acaba de pasar
cerca de donde me encuentro en este
momento esos son los cánticos de las
personas en la calle acá estaba acaba de
pasar ahora mismo una familia con tres
niños con bandera celebrando el apruebo
ondeando las banderas la calle es una
auténtica fiesta en este momento muy
bien patricia vamos estar pendientes
contigo del desarrollo de esta jornada y
de estas atípicas votaciones pues vaya
están en medio de pandemia y están
extremando las medidas de seguridad
hablamos ahora con sandra ponce de léon
nuestra invitada especialista en derecho
constitucional chileno
muchas gracias abogada nuevamente por
estar con nosotros cuáles son sus
primeras impresiones de la jornada de
votación chilena
buenas noches alan
mira las primeras impresiones son bueno
lo que ustedes han dicho que se ha
alzado con mucha fuerza la opción del
apruebo en lo cierto en comparación con
el rechazo y ha llevado alrededor de
cerca del 80 por ciento de aprobaciones
a esa opción y respecto del órgano por
el que la gente quiere que redacte esa
nueva constitución también se ha alzado
con mayoría la convención constitucional
que como bien decían ustedes estaría
formada por 155 personas que son
elegidas directamente por la población
así que esa es la reacción digamos desde
desde la perspectiva de los resultados y
como veíamos recién también hay una
sensación de júbilo no ser todo respecto
de este esta estancia que tenía no
cierto la mayoría de la ciudadanía de
que se hicieran cambios
no sé si tan profundo o no pero cambios
efectivamente a la constitución que nos
rige actualmente votar en medio de una
pandemia siendo chile uno de los más
impactados a nivel mundial por el
coronavirus además un lapicero azul para
no estar dando diferentes lapiceros y
estar pasando en un posible virus a las
personas un horario especial para las
personas de tercera edad porque era
necesario celebrar el plebiscito este
domingo
bueno como también decían el plebiscito
fue cambiando de fecha y se pensó que en
octubre en la pandemia en chile iba a
tener una baja como efectivamente sucede
pero de todas maneras en nosotros
estamos en una situación de un cierto
desaliento de a poco de la desconcierto
y por lo tanto había que dar también
para dar legitimidad a este plebiscito
había que dotar dotarlo no cierto de
medidas de seguridad para que las
personas pudieran ir tranquilas a votar
y esto de llevar el lápiz azul de cada
uno no siempre será una recomendación
sin perjuicio de que habían lápices en
las mesas también se permitía el acceso
a los locales de votación de manera muy
ordenada yo creo que fue exitoso en ese
sentido la la jornada de a porque no vi
mayores reclamo efectivamente respecto
de la situación sanitaria sino que todo
lo contrario había
menor cantidad de contacto o sea casi no
había contacto con los vocales y eso
también les garantizaba a ellos una
seguridad no es cierto en la salud muy
bien sandra ponce vamos a seguir contigo
pero ahora me comunico con elisa o
walker ella también es abogada
especialista en constitución chilena
elisa también te agradezco nuevamente
esta comunicación los votantes
respondieron a dos preguntas en dos
boletas diferentes hablábamos primero
sobre el cambio de constitución si o no
y la otra sobre el órgano que lo
redactará para analistas electorales la
verdadera pregunta era la segunda pues
la primera parecía contundente que
querían el cambio constitucional
hablemos entonces sobre la segunda la
que va ganando si sale una convención
constitucional como parece el caso que
perfil deberían de tener pues los
responsables de una nueva constitución
chilena
muchas gracias a alan por la pregunta y
la invitación primero tener en cuenta
que esta primera vez en nuestra
tradición republicana que vamos a
construir una constitución en democracia
y por eso este es un día de júbilo en
relación a tu pregunta a cabo una amplia
mayoría que optó por la posibilidad de
que la constitución sea redactada por
una convención constitucional lo
fundamental de eso es que el 100 por
ciento de quienes integran esta
convención van a ser directamente
elegidos por la ciudadanía el próximo 11
de abril del año 2021 entonces la
principal conclusión de este fenómeno es
entender que acá hay ansias de
participación hay compromiso con el
presente y el futuro de nuestro país y
eso se ve reflejado en la los resultados
de las elecciones que la tendencia ya es
concluyente verdad el 100 por ciento de
las mesas no está resuelta pero la
tendencia
si ya está firme si sale una convención
constitucional como parece el caso esta
carta magna será paritaria esto sería
una novedad mundial estaría redactada
con la mitad de mujeres qué opinión te
merece esto y qué opinión también te
merecería si es que tendría integrantes
o escaños para por los originarios
así es este proceso constituyente va a
ser un referente a nivel internacional
porque esta va a ser la primera vez que
hombres y mujeres igualmente
representados participen en esta
discusión qué duda cabe que el siglo 21
si hay algo importante que tiene es como
permitido visibilizar escuchar y
permitir la participación de mujeres
esto es un proceso en evolución que han
muchas materias también pendientes pero
en chile- los últimos años a pesar de
que la lucha sobre la mujer ha sido
histórica hemos tomado especial
conciencia política sobre la importancia
de no solo escuchar la voz sino que
también que las mujeres puedan
participar también en los procesos
políticos y esta constitución va a ser
el mejor reflejo de lo anterior y eso
también permite no sólo incorporar
nuevas miradas sino que también
incorporar nuevos temas de discusión
normalmente los temas que interesan a
las mujeres son relegados a un segundo o
un tercer plano porque ellas no tienen
mucha representación en los espacios
públicos y ahora sí lo van a tener
con la participación de los pueblos
originarios esto no es novedoso en
colombia por ejemplo ustedes mismos
tuvieron una experiencia de
participación de pueblos originarios en
la creación de una nueva constitución
pero si lo interesante es que en chile
vale la pena recalcarlo porque por
ejemplo la constitución actual que los
rige no hay referencia alguna a los
pueblos originarios de chile tenemos una
deuda histórica sobre los pueblos
originarios y una forma de empezar a
reparar esa deuda histórica es asegurar
la participación de los mismos el
mecanismo de participación de los
pueblos originarios todavía no está
resuelto todavía eso se está discutiendo
el congreso nacional pero sin duda
figura va a haber un mecanismo no así
como la situación de las mujeres en que
ya el mecanismo está resuelto y está
asegurado el 50 por ciento de su
presencia en el resultado no cambia edad
no candidatura sino que asegurar la
participación en el resultado de las
músicas muy bien elisa walker muchas
gracias también seguiré contigo durante
él
recorrido de este especial momento de
actualizar cómo van los resultados
electorales porque insistimos son dos
preguntas las que se están realizando en
esta consulta que terminó y que ahora ya
están haciendo los conteos en la
pregunta uno quiere usted una nueva
constitución los porcentajes sobre el si
77 puntos 97 por ciento sobre él no
queremos modificar la constitución 22 03
por ciento esas dos últimas barras que
ven son referentes a la pregunta número
dos qué órgano debería redactar esta
nueva constitución una convención mixta
que lo explicaban nuestras especialistas
compuesta por 172 miembros tiene al
momento 20 95 por ciento mientras que
una convención constitucional 79 05 por
ciento estamos hablando de un total de
mesas escrutadas en nivel de porcentaje
de 62.2 por ciento vamos a estar
actualizando por supuesto
estos datos que parecen contundentes y
que se acercan a cerrar una votación
rápida la que está sucediendo en chile y
también vamos a analizar un poquito
sobre los escenarios que se vendrían
ante este inminente si al cambio andrés
rincón nos cuenta por qué se votó y
cuáles serían los escenarios si los
chilenos eligen redactar esta nueva
carta magna
los plebiscitos siempre han estado
marcados por cambios históricos en chile
fue precisamente el de 1988 el que selló
el retorno de la democracia en el país
con la salida del dictador augusto
pinochet de quien chile heredó la
constitución que rige en la actualidad
pero el estallido social que sacudió al
país en octubre de 2019 puso en el
centro de sus demandas la convocatoria a
un nuevo proceso constituyente que
terminó siendo aprobado por el
presidente sebastián piñera un mes
después pese a que unos 15 millones de
chilenos están habilitados no es
obligatorio votar sin embargo el
plebiscito se responderá en dos
papeletas quiere usted una nueva
constitución que tendrá las opciones
apruebo y rechazó en la segunda deberán
responder qué tipo de órgano deberá
redactar la constitución aquí los
chilenos tienen dos opciones elegir una
convención constitucional compuesta
únicamente de ciudadanos electos para
este fin o una convención mixta
compuesta en un 50% por parlamentarios y
en otro 50% por ciudadanos
si los chilenos aprueban una nueva
constitución o cualquiera que sea la
convención elegida para redactar la
sería partidaria y chile sería el único
país en el mundo en el que hombres y
mujeres repartidos equitativamente
diseñaría la carta magna
un montón de largo que empezaría el 11
de abril de 2021 con la elección de los
integrantes de la convención ganadora
quienes tendrían entre 9 y 11 meses para
redactar la constitución que en el
segundo semestre de 2022 sería sometida
a un nuevo plebiscito cuyo voto sería
obligatorio si es aprobada entraría en
vigor de inmediato de ser rechazada la
constitución de 1980 seguirá rigiendo
los caminos de chile y su modificación
dependería de la iniciativa presidencial
retomamos con nuestra corresponsal de
france 24 en santiago patricia luna
quien ya la tenemos en vídeo ya te vemos
ahí en medio de este júbilo que tienen
varios chilenos
patricia también hablemos del impacto
mental social de este plebiscito es un
tema que se tiene que abordar y es que
la constitución redactada y aprobada
bajo la dictadura de augusto pinochet
nació de un acto de fuerza de violencia
en un clima de miedo chile muestra hoy
que quería generar una constitución sin
traumas
[Música]
bueno me parece que así es hemos visto
en los últimos días una expresión en las
redes sociales expresión de mucha gente
también en la calle que afirmaba que de
alguna forma la prueba iniciar una nueva
constitución supone el enterrar un poco
el legado de la dictadura por fin al
dejar esta página totalmente atrás
cuando hemos hablado con la gente en la
calle sobre lo que nos trataba de
comunicar que ellos se sienten hijos
nietos de la dictadura y que no quieren
de alguna forma el amarre que eso
significa ni tampoco las amarras
constitucionales que se implicó en esta
sociedad que tras cada vez que ha
tratado de modificar hacia una mejora
social de cualquier tipo se ha visto con
la barrera de que muchas de las leyes
serán clasificadas como
anticonstitucionales yo creo que sí
hemos visto mensajes en los que se vota
la constitución a la basura en las que
se entierra a pinochet en los que se
hace alusiones específicas a ese pasado
que todavía saca heridas y muestra
divisiones en esta sociedad y de alguna
forma esto implica una nueva etapa
empezar desde cero empezar un nuevo
libro
que partía pues un poco en esta nueva
constitución que tomara cosas de las
pasadas o no pero que implicará un nuevo
chile un chile pensado sin amarres cine
sin viejos legados y sin esa imagen de
pinochet que de alguna forma ha
prolongado su sombra alargada en esta
sociedad en los últimos 40 años
patricia para marcar este contraste con
el origen de la vieja constitución
la nueva debían nacer en un entorno
pacífico y es que las protestas y la
violencia que se han observado en los
últimos meses desde el año anterior pues
logran este objetivo
bueno este es un tema el que se ha
debatido mucho en chile especialmente
veíamos la celebración del estallido de
la semana pasada en la que en la que
hubo bastantes actos de violencia una
violencia que se manifestó a última hora
de la tarde cuando muchísima parte de la
población se había manifestado durante
todo el día de forma pacífica la
violencia ha estado siempre presente y
ha sido muy discutida dentro de la
sociedad chilena que de alguna forma
rechaza este tipo de actos y con el que
no concuerda todo el mundo para algunos
la violencia es el camino necesario para
ser escuchado puesto que las demandas no
habían sido escuchadas de alguna forma
no habían sido tomadas en cuenta en
anteriores manifestaciones pero muchos
otros discrepan de que este a través de
saqueos de quemas de iglesias que como
han dado la vuelta al mundo no es el
camino para lograr un nuevo chile las
manifestaciones que se produjo justo
hace un año el 25 de octubre del 2019
que fue la más masiva que concentró a
una gran cantidad de personas que se
manifestaron de forma pacífica y de
alguna forma el estallido
con el incremento de la violencia
también fue restando cantidad de gente
de las calles que se veía un poco
abrumada por esta cantidad de violencias
es un debate que tiene que seguir
llevando adelante la sociedad chilena en
donde el tema de la violencia y de los
actos violentos aparecen en el debate
público de panamá constante muy bien
patricia pues ahí seguiremos contigo en
medio de este ambiente en el que
observamos de júbilo de los chilenos
primero un par de preguntas para
nuestros especialistas
constitucionalistas chilenas empiezo con
sandra ponce de léon cerramos este tema
el tema social dado que los chilenos no
pudieron encarcelar a pinochet por
violaciones de derechos humanos escribir
una nueva constitución considera que
podría ser como un acto de expiación
para los chilenos
a ver efectivamente tener una
constitución redactada en una época
donde hay normalidad no es cierto social
y en un sistema no es cierto de facto
evidentemente que es mucho mejor
eso no lo duda nadie y yo creo que todos
estamos de acuerdo en esa en esa
posición ahora y claro se dice la
mayoría de la gente no cierto dice que
la constitución del año 80 nos divide y
que sería ilegítima en cuanto a su
origen y eso es lo que se estaría de
alguna manera mejorando o eliminando no
cierto esa ilegitimidad de origen a
través de un nuevo proceso
constitucional
pero también hay que reconocer que la
constitución del año 1980 ha sido
modificada 54 o sea 52 veces si no mal
no recuerdo
y han sido afectadas más de 200 normas
en estos años y las mayores
modificaciones serán producidos en una
anterior estará el sistema democrático
en el año 89 por un gran acuerdo
político también y en el año 2005
incluso en esa oportunidad se llegó a
decir que ya no teníamos la misma
constitución que estaba firmada por el
presidente lago
entonces de alguna manera aún así aún
habiéndose
he producido esos acuerdos políticos que
modificaron en gran parte esos esos
enclaves autoritarios que tenían la
constitución en su texto original de
todas maneras no ha dejado al parecer un
cierto web con toda la sociedad con la
sensación de que estamos con un texto
redactado en democracia sin perjuicio de
todas esas modificaciones y en ese
sentido creo yo que el plebiscito de hoy
día o el llamado que se hizo por las
fuerzas políticas a la ciudadanía
pronunciarse ha sido claro
quiere la población tener un 1
un texto en el que puedan concluir toda
la fuerza precisamente le quiero
preguntar qué tan drásticos deberían de
ser estos cambios que usted ya no se
identificó varias reformas a la
constitución y que no todo era malo en
la constitución de pinochet permitió el
avance del país en muchos aspectos
incluido el de la alternancia pacífica y
democrática de poder entre piñera y la
líder de izquierda de michelle bachelet
más allá de los temas álgidos como la
distribución del poder los bienes
públicos los derechos civiles agua
vivienda educación que tan drásticos
deben ser los nuevos cambios
a ver yo creo que cuando se ha hablado
en el pacto político de noviembre del
año pasado cuando se nos refirió está
esta posibilidad de consultarle a la
ciudadanía si quería o no una nueva
constitución se habló de la hoja en
blanco ya y esa hoja en blanco no puede
con cierto ser partir de cero
la idea esa hoja en blanco es discutir
sentarse a la mesa a ponerse de acuerdo
sobre los aspectos básicos que debe
tener no es cierto por lo menos la
estructura del estado y los derechos
fundamentales de las personas que son
las dos partes fundamentales de una
constitución yo creo que la lógica es
mantener lo bueno que tenemos en la
constitución no todo es malo tenemos una
tradición constitucional en chile que ya
viene de los reglamentos de 1818 con
otras constituciones del 33 del 25 la
misma constitución del 80 52 veces
reformada no es cierto y ha sido la
misma constitución del 80 la que ha
permitido en definitiva también
llevar adelante este proceso con ese
acuerdo mayoritario de las 10 fuerzas
políticas representadas en el congreso
nacional entonces yo creo que hay que
rescatar lo bueno que tenemos en la
constitución por ejemplo nadie puede
discutir hoy día que las personas nacen
libres e iguales en dignidad y derecho
como lo declara en la misma constitución
que la familia es el núcleo fundamental
de la sociedad y hay que protegerla que
hay no es cierto una separación de
funciones del poder ejecutivo del
gobierno el poder legislativo del
congreso nacional y los tribunales
justicia y es ciertos órganos que deben
ser autónomos de todas esas autoridades
para poder cumplir bien sus roles por
ejemplo nosotros tenemos un banco
central que está concierto dedicado al
la fijación de la política monetaria del
el de los créditos etcétera y no es
cierto es importante mantener esa
autonomía por ejemplo de este banco muy
bien muchas gracias boga ponce de león
ya regreso con usted ahora pasó con
elisa walker magíster en derecho y en
filosofía por estos puntos abogada que
no se identificó sandra ponce león es
posible que una nueva constitución se
parezca bastante a la actual las
expectativas pueden quedar frustradas
una constitución tiene tres elementos
principales que la configuran primero un
aspecto de valor y ccoo de cómo se
sienten identificados los chilenos y las
chilenas y se reflejan en la
constitución también un aspecto sobre
derecho y garantía y también cómo se
organiza y se distribuye el poder en
estas tres materias probablemente van a
ver una revisión profunda de las mismas
y ya hay elementos que van a cambiar y
probablemente también hay otros que se
van a mantener
no se hablaba por ejemplo del banco
central dúo que voy a ser objeto de una
discusión profunda del reconocimiento la
igualdad también a la autonomía de
ciertos órganos eso probablemente no va
a cambiar en forma profunda si vamos a
tener cambios significativos en cuanto
al reconocimiento de los derechos y
garantías desde el estallido social el
año pasado en chile en uno podría decir
la gran mayoría de los cabildos
ciudadanos que se desarrollaron en el
país habían tres temas principales de
interés que convocan a la ciudadanía
educación salud
y esos son los derechos sociales
entonces va a haber una discusión de
fondo sobre los derechos sociales que es
también el núcleo esencial de la
constitución del 80 que hasta ahora ha
sido modificado porque es verdad que ha
habido hartas reformas que han cambiado
el texto original pero si hay un núcleo
esencial que prácticamente no se ha
modificado desde el 80 a la fecha son
los derechos sociales y ahí va a haber
una discusión intensa también va a haber
una discusión importante sobre lo
valórico sobre cómo nos vemos
representados los chilenos y las
chilenas en la constitución yo ya
hablaba de los pueblos originarios la
constitución actual no dice nada solo
sobre los pueblos originarios
probablemente y uno de los reclamos que
se hace es poder establecer que chile es
un estado plurinacional también las
familias las familias efectivamente la
constitución actual dice que son el
pilar fundamental de nuestra sociedad
pero la pregunta es quién compone esas
familias cuál es la notificación de
familia que está
de esa protección en una familia
convencional tradicionalmente constituía
hombre mujer niños o es una visión
amplia y extendida de lo que pueden ser
familias incluyendo abuelos con nietos
incluyendo parejas homosexuales que
puedan tener un claro y fuerte
reconocimiento constitucional y
finalmente también la forma en que se
organiza el poder político también va a
ser fuerte fuente de discusión partiendo
por ejemplo con el tipo de gobierno que
tenemos nosotros en chile tenemos un
gobierno hiperpresidencialista un
sistema de gobierno
hiperpresidencialista que concentra la
gran mayoría de las tomas de decisiones
políticas de nuestro país en el
presidente de la república y no es desde
el último tiempo sino que desde varios
años había un cuestionamientos el
sistema y la pregunta a dónde vamos a
transitar vamos a transitar por ejemplo
a un sistema parlamentario o vamos a
transitar por ejemplo a un sistema semi
presidencialista las respuestas todavía
no están claras pero yo diría que los
diagnósticos
más o menos claros abogado a walker y
era este plebiscito la vía para
disminuir la ira que hay en los chilenos
mire es que chile es un país con
problemas similares a los desafíos que
enfrentan otros latinoamericanos
incluidos la falta de crecimiento
sostenible la escasa creación de empleo
la desigualdad es la nueva constitución
la mejor manera de resolver los
problemas
en chile hay una preocupación profunda
sobre los problemas de desigualdad y
evidentemente la constitución no va a
resolver todos los problemas pero si es
la base sobre la cual se que se
establecen nuestras instituciones y esa
base tiene que ser sólida tiene que ser
compartida por todos los chilenos y
también tenemos que sentir un sentido de
pertenencia hacia la misma hacerla
propia ese sentido identitario de
pertenencia que está fuertemente
afectado desde el origen hasta la fecha
en la constitución actual y la creación
de una nueva constitución es la
posibilidad de reformar lo es verdad lo
que decían en el reportaje y quedan solo
la situación política actual de chile
que tenemos una situación más compleja
en términos políticos tenemos
situaciones de violencia que nos tiene
que llamar la atención a todos y que es
importante siempre levantar una voz
clara y decidida en contra de la
violencia pero así también es cierto que
durante el gobierno de la presidenta de
bachelet que él
en el periodo presidencial anterior que
antecede al presidente piñera hubo la
posibilidad de hacer un proceso
constituyente y muchos decían no es
necesario una nueva constitución porque
las cosas están bien y ahora que tenemos
una crisis institucional más profunda
muchos dicen no hay que cambiar la
constitución porque las condiciones no
son las ideales que es lo que demuestra
esto que los problemas tienen que
resolverse en forma adecuada y eso
influye tanto en el contenido y también
en los momentos y en nuestro país llegó
el momento en que todos los chilenos y
chilenas podemos conversar e insisto por
primera vez en nuestra tradición
republicana enuncia bajo un sistema
democrático conversar sobre cuál
queremos que sea el contenido de nuestra
constitución con una mirada de presente
y también de futuro muy bien elisa
walker vamos a seguir contigo pero
momento de ver cómo se desarrollan los
resultados de esta jornada en la que se
prevé una participación histórica una de
las más altas sino la más alta desde
que se instauró el voto voluntario en
2012 sobre la pregunta uno quiere usted
una nueva constitución
apruebo 78,12 por ciento
rechazo 21 88% sobre la pregunta 2 cómo
se realizaría qué órgano convención
mixta 20,9 por ciento mientras que
convención constitucional 79 10% ojo a
este porcentaje de mesas escrutadas se
está llegando rápidamente a la totalidad
de las mesas 76 53 por ciento al momento
estos son resultados en directo y ya nos
hablaba la abogada de lisa walker sobre
lo que inició como reclamo por el alza
en el pasaje del metro en chile que se
convirtió rápidamente en un masivo
movimiento que expuso las desigualdades
sociales del país y es que esta es una
oportunidad que los chilenos parece
aprovecharon para modificar y cambiar la
constitución lograrlo
no fue fácil fueron meses de protestas
antigubernamentales y disturbios se lo
mostramos en el siguiente informe
en octubre de 2019 cientos de chilenos
se lanzaron a las calles sin saber que
un año después tendrían la oportunidad
de decidir sobre una nueva constitución
rechazaban el alza a los precios del
pasaje del metro de santiago y aunque la
medida fue retirada las protestas
continuaron y se extendieron a nivel
nacional algunas de manera pacífica y
otras derivaron en saqueos y daños en el
transporte público
por modelos implacable rápidamente la
protesta se convirtió en un movimiento
que se prolongó durante meses inconforme
ante las desigualdades sociales del país
que era cambios profundos profundos
desde la educación la salud las
pensiones todo
el despliegue de la fuerza para contener
el estallido social puso al presidente
sebastián piñera en la lupa de la
comunidad internacional señalando lo de
ser el responsable de violaciones de
derechos humanos el 30 de noviembre de
2019 amnistía internacional había
contabilizado más de 300 lesiones
oculares por balas de goma y el 6 de
diciembre la oficina de derechos humanos
de la onu documentaba 28 mil detenciones
entre las cuales había denuncias de
torturas y violencia sexual
la crisis obligó al gobierno a dar paso
a la creación de una nueva carta magna y
reemplazar a través de un referéndum la
heredada de la dictadura de augusto
pinochet
la consulta estaba programada para el 26
de abril pero el brote de kobe 19 no
sólo provocó su aplazamiento sino que
también ahogó en gran medida las
protestas la palabra plebiscito tiene
gran peso en chile en 1988 el pueblo
votó para sacar a pinochet y devolver al
país a la democracia ahora los chilenos
buscan aprovechar esta oportunidad para
cimentar la igualdad y borrar una oscura
mancha del que hasta hace unos meses era
uno de los países más estables de
américa latina y ahora enlazamos con
nuestra corresponsal de france 24 en la
capital chilena en santiago patricia
estamos viendo aquí sobre las protestas
es que era la única forma de conseguir
los cambios políticos está este
referendo este plebiscito la gente salía
a las calles priorizando una nueva
constitución era este el motivo por el
que se manifestaban
bueno esta fue una de las consignas más
repetidas que vimos desde luego desde el
comienzo del estallido en el pasado año
en octubre es cierto que como mencionaba
antes sí que la constitución está
presente en el hecho de que muchas
normas políticas se ha argumentado que
son inconstitucionales para poder hacer
cambios en el país y cuando se lanzaron
en un poco antes se produjo el estallido
social real y mucha gente salía a la
calle al manifestando su deseo de una
nueva constitución en pancartas lo hemos
visto muchísimas veces en los muros de
la calle e incluso de forma didáctica
explicando lo que es una constitución
los derechos que tienen que tener los
derechos que tienen que cambiar como se
forjó la constitución actual el hecho de
que se forjó en cuatro paredes que
favorece los intereses de algunas
personas esta semana hablábamos en la
calle con un estudiante y él nos decía
no la constitución está muy bien hecha
pero beneficia a los empresarios del
país no beneficia a la gente del pueblo
ese es un poco la idea que se tiene
una idea extendida entre los chilenos es
por eso que es verdad que uno de los
principales reclamos que es uno leía las
pancartas del año pasado era cambiar la
constitución y esto es algo que se ve
reflejado en la cantidad de gente que ha
acudido a votar hoy gente de todas las
edades hemos visto imágenes de ancianos
de personas de 100 años ya pudieran a
votar de muchísima gente joven que no
había participado tanto en anteriores
procesos electorales y que hoy salió a
la calle a darlo todo a dar su opinión
es muy generalizado yo iba haciendo una
encuesta durante el día preguntando a
personas en la calle porque habían
votado una inmensa mayoría de las
personas creían que un cambio
constitucional iba a ser el primer paso
para solucionar algunos de los problemas
que tienen que tiene chile no de forma
inmediata pero sí sentar un poco las
bases para poder construir una sociedad
diferente es verdad que el cambio
constitucional es algo que se ha
repetido mucho y de hecho durante el
estallido la constitución alcanzó cifras
de venta
nunca vistas en la historia uno caminaba
por la calle y lo veía en los puestos
callejeros y se convirtió en uno de los
textos más leídos pues el momento en que
los chilenos tomaron conciencia de que
tenían de que conocer bien su carta
magna para saber cuáles eran los
elementos que los apresaban un poco como
sociedad y esa es la idea que existe un
poco en la sociedad que la constitución
ha funcionado un poco como una cadena
para impedir cambios y es que como bien
identificas patricia las protestas no
sólo se trataban de cambios a la
constitución algunos incluso decían que
está bien redactada sino que también se
protestaban por el alto costo de las
facturas de electricidad del combustible
del transporte público cómo debe
responder viendo los resultados que van
al momento del contundentes y al cambio
de constitución como debe responder el
gobierno y como escuchaste el
pronunciamiento del presidente sebastián
piñera
bueno el presidente tuve esta mañana la
gran duda en las últimas días era el que
iba a votar el presidente del gobierno
porque él nunca manifestó un poco su
postura sobre este plebiscito aunque sí
lo hicieron otros miembros de su
gobierno y era la gran incógnita cuando
votó esta mañana dijo que una gran
mayoría de los chilenos estaban por el
cambio constitucional no sabemos si él
se estaba incluyendo ahí pero la verdad
es que creo que el presidente piñera
[Música]
manifestó un poco que los cambios eran
necesarios
en los cambios sociales es hora
en esta isla
momento
patricia pues vemos claramente como este
tema es un tema pasional y que por ello
se llega a una votación histórica
participación récord en medio en medio
de pandemia y los resultados están
saliendo al momento ya falta menos del
20 por ciento te invito patricia que
veas con nosotros cómo van los
resultados en este momento 78 17
aprueban el cambio a la constitución 21
83 por ciento rechazan que la
constitución se cambie qué órgano sería
responsable una convención mixta 20 79
por ciento mientras que una convención
constitucional 79 21 por ciento mesas
escrutadas 82 punto 25% está haciendo
este conteo rápido es el conteo oficial
no es abocado una entonces estamos ya
muy cerca de la totalidad del 100 por
ciento al ser esto inminente vamos a
hablar de los cambios del
formas que tendría la carta magna-
chilena seguirá siendo por ejemplo uno
de los temas polémicos el agua seguirá
siendo el agua privada es el único país
del mundo donde esto ocurre de patricia
[Música]
y hemos visto en los últimos días a
muchas personas que pedían o que
afirmaban incluso en la franja electoral
en la que se transmite en televisión
muchas se se emitía esta frase de que
chile necesita una nueva constitución
porque era el único país es el único
país del mundo donde el agua es privada
este es uno de los temas también que
hemos visto en la calle donde mucha
gente decía que necesitamos una nueva
constitución que se necesita una nueva
constitución en el país que proteja los
recursos ambientales es uno de los temas
que preocupan los chilenos especialmente
cuando tenemos situaciones como las que
se producen en petroria que ahora ha
aparecido en todos los medios en la
comuna de valparaíso donde la gente no
tiene agua para beber pero se producen
faltas que se exportan a europa ya
muchos otros lugares del mundo y que son
muy cuantiosas o muy costosas de
producir en términos de agua es decir
hay un tema con el hecho de que las
mineras por ejemplo en el norte del país
ocupan una gran cantidad de agua
mientras que hay una gran cantidad de
chilenos que no tienen acceso por
ejemplo al agua
esta ha sido como uno de los temas
icónicos también que se ha utilizado
para defender el derecho a que exista
una nueva constitución es muy improbable
que la nueva constitución si está
escrita por el pueblo y por la
convención constitucional no tenga esto
en cuenta porque ha sido un tema que se
ha debatido arduamente en los últimos
meses en los últimos años en estos
momentos en la que la región
metropolitana tiene un problema de
sequía importante ya que uno de los
principales lugares que abastece a
santiago el envase del yeso se encuentra
en niveles mínimos es un tema constante
que hemos visto también cuando chile
sufrió una mega sequía el año pasado y
en mi proyección o mi apuesta sería que
una nueva constitución desde luego el
agua sería un derecho de los ciudadanos
de los chilenos como ocurre en otros
lugares del mundo muy bien patricia luna
pues ahí seguimos contigo en las calles
de santiago momento de hablar con la
abogada sandra ponce de léon sandra está
de acuerdo con lo pronunciado por
nuestra corresponsal de france 24 en la
capital chilena seguir haciendo
privada qué posibilidades también hay de
nacionalizar la extracción del litio y
de cobre
bueno ustedes saben que en chile es esto
que se dice que el agua es privada claro
ahí hay una lectura en esa parte que a
lo mejor puede tener algún tipo de
confusión en chile el agua es un bien
nacional de uso público es decir que
pertenece a todos nosotros y el uso
también de esa agua es común pero como
sucede en la mayoría de los casos de los
de los bienes de dominio público en el
mundo sobre esos bienes puede el estado
entregar usos privativos
a los particulares en una cierta
cantidad si tú logras acreditar que hay
agua en un lugar el estado lo que hace
es revisar los estudios técnicos
etcétera y está obligado a entregarte el
agua lo malo acá fue que en la década
del 80 cuando se dicta el primer código
de agua no se establece un pago por el
uso de esos derechos de aprovechamiento
que se llama que son usuales en los
bienes nacionales los bienes públicos
como se les denomina en general
en el mundo
y ahora lo que lo que sí sucede en chile
por eso que ahí está esta idea de que el
agua es privada es que esos derechos de
uso y de goce que obtienes tú a través
de una resolución de la autoridad
administrativa pueden ser transadas en
el mercado entonces no importa la
propiedad no es cierto del terreno donde
tu estés ejerciendo ese derecho porque
el derecho puede ser transado libremente
en el mercado entonces hoy día como les
digo es un bien de todos pero la fórmula
que se utilizó o que se ideó en un
principio para entregar estos derechos
aprovechamientos no satisface a lo mejor
esta necesidad que tienen las personas
evidentemente de que se dé preferencia
al consumo humano y no al industrial
respecto del agua el agua y díaz está
concedida en muchos ciertos niveles en
nuestro país lo que sí se ha reformado
es que ese derecho a usar el agua
lleva aparejado el pago de una de un
derecho lo que lo que usa en el agua y
los que tampoco la usan pero tienen esos
derechos aprovechamientos tienen que
pagar por esos derechos qué es lo que
pasaría no cierto el día mañana cuando
se dejará por ejemplo sin efecto esos
derechos privativos que tú has otorgado
durante todos estos años a esas personas
van a reclamar precisamente por su
derecho a propiedad algún tipo de
indemnización y eso es lo complejo de
como el estado no sé si estará pensando
o teniendo los recursos necesarios como
para llevar adelante esa esa medida
ahora en cuanto a los derechos mineros
también las minas en chile son del
estado
lo que hace el estado es entregar en
concesión también este derecho de un
solo sector
la posibilidad de explotar los minerales
que existan en el manto terrestre y la
persona solamente se hace dueña de los
minerales una vez que lo extraer ahora
porque esta fórmula porque chile
no tenía en su momento a lo mejor hoy
día ha cambiado no es cierto la la
posibilidad económica de explotar no es
cierto todo el mineral que tenía lo que
salió recién en algún en alguna nota de
que chile no tenía participación del
estado en la minería
eso también es falso porque tenemos a
codelco chile que es una empresa pública
creada por ley y que maneja no es cierto
también el mineral desde la perspectiva
del estado sí pero también tenemos
intervención de privados y eso molesta
que siente en qué sentido en que
aparecer los impuestos que se pagan por
ese uso por esa concesión serían bajos y
eso es lo que hay que reformar de alguna
manera igual que en el caso de las aguas
porque imagínense ustedes propias o
nacionalizar es hoy día que significaría
como costo para todos los chiles
si abogada y hablemos de otro de los
temas álgidos también las pensiones que
han sido un tema de protestas en chile
durante años cómo se podría mejorar este
asunto en uno o dos minutos para que
estemos actualizando los resultados de
abogar si en el derecho el derecho a la
seguridad social ya en chile
efectivamente existe un sector en hacer
toda la posibilidad con la forma de
intervención del estado que se ha
mantenido hasta el día de hoy que a lo
mejor puede cambiar el día mañana ha
permitido que en este en este ámbito
funcionen administradoras de fondos de
pensiones que el estado solamente se ha
dedicado a fiscalizar a controlar el
ejercicio de esa función no ser por esa
actividad privada pero que dice en
relación con la administración de los
fondos de cada uno de los particulares
de cada uno de los chilenos no es un
sistema que
o sea que en definitiva en la teoría
funcione mal cada cada trabajador es
propietario de sus fondos para jubilar
lo que sucede aquí es que el manejo de
esos fondos no ha dado no sentir manejo
que han tenido las afp no ha dado el
ancho como se dice y por lo tanto ahí
habría que modificar pero no sé si
modificando la constitución sino hay que
modificando el régimen legal que se
aplica al sistema de pensiones yo creo
que sería ya han estado muchos años
tratando de modificarlo yo creo que las
bases lo cierto de esas modificaciones a
lo mejor podríamos integrarla algunos
principios básicos en la constitución
pero más bien se refiere a una cuestión
legal y de política pública no es cierto
esa modificación eso es lo que pienso yo
bien muy bien abogada ponce de léon
seguiremos con usted y seguimos también
con este tema sobre los posibles cambios
los principales que tendría una nueva
magna chilena ante el inminente si en
este plebiscito ahora pasó con elisa
walker ella es nuestra abogada magíster
en derecho y filosofía que otros temas
resaltasen las posibles reformas que se
vayan a realizar habló de los álgidos
que ya mencionaron nuestras invitadas
anteriores y también de el acceso a la
educación es un tema que no se ha
abordado
efectivamente yo he hablado de los
derechos sociales
y ahí particularmente el derecho a la
educación y el derecho a la salud van a
ser fuertemente discutidos nuestra la
constitución actual en chile no es
neutra frente a cómo pueden diseñarse
las políticas públicas relacionadas con
educación con salud sino que establece
claramente los límites de una posible
política pública sobre la materia
límites que están fuertemente arraigados
en el principio de subsidiaridad en la
idea de que el estado no tiene un deber
preferente para otorgar ciertas
garantías o derechos a los ciudadanos y
ciudadanas del país sino que más bien el
estado se resta o permite que primero
existe la participación de privados o
órganos intermedios entidades
intermedias pero luego frente a la
ausencia de la participación de ellos el
estado pueda desarrollar esa labor de
entonces va a ver un fuerte
cuestionamiento a ese rol
y potenciar el rol del estado nuevo
significa necesariamente estatizar a
estas funciones no es que el estado va a
tener que hacer todas estas funciones
pero sí entender que el estado no puede
estar a la cola no puede estar al final
de la fila sino que tiene una
responsabilidad principal que por lo
demás es parte de nuestra tradición
republicana constitucional en chile- el
estado siempre tuvo un deber preferente
de otorgar atención en temas de
educación en temas de salud pero fue la
constitución del 80 la que quebró con
esa tradición republicana y dejó al
estado como decía yo al final de la fila
sobre cómo se prestan estas maestras
este estos servicios verdad y estas
atenciones entonces como yo les decía
puede haber una definición de políticas
públicas pero el margen de lo posible
está definido en la constitución y
justamente ese margen de lo posible lo
que probablemente va a ser revisado para
un nuevo texto constitucional abogado a
chile ha sido durante varios años un
ejemplo de progreso económico llegando a
estar entre los más altos
de la región latinoamericana más allá de
las desigualdades que le criticaban a
esta constitución algunos financieros
chilenos les preocupa que redactar una
nueva carta magna amenaza pues lo que
hizo de chile un modelo económico
regional
la estabilidad económica de nuestro país
es importante pero esa estabilidad
económica viene de la mano de una
estabilidad política y de una
estabilidad social entonces justamente
este proceso constituyente es importante
para efectos de promover una estabilidad
económica porque vamos a tener una
discusión constitucional pero es una
discusión que tiene un principio y un
fin en el tiempo he aquí los llamados a
discutir la constitución van a tener
nueve meses para redactar la que puede
ser ampliable por otros tres meses más
sin dudar a una sin lugar a duda vamos a
tener un año para discutir redactar una
nueva constitución que finalmente va a
ser ofrecía a la ciudadanía a través de
un plebiscito de salida en el cual los
ciudadanos y ciudadanas puedan decir si
finalmente adhieren o no a esta
constitución para que se transforme en
el nuevo texto constitucional
le da estabilidad institucional a
nuestro país y el desarrollo económico
de un país necesita de esa estabilidad
institucional en ese sentido van de la
mano los que queremos una nueva
constitución no estamos en contra de un
desarrollo económico pero entendemos que
un desarrollo económico sostenible en el
tiempo tiene que ir de la mano también
de un desarrollo social adecuado y es
ahí donde está el principal reclamo del
desarrollo de nuestro país y esto
obviamente no significa que se ha hecho
todo mal para nada han habido grandes
avances en varias materias estamos
orgullosos de la actualidad de nuestro
país pero también hay aspectos que hay
que desarrollar con más profundidad la
inclusión el disminuir las brechas de
desigualdad justamente son los aspectos
que hay que fortalecer para esta
estabilidad institucional y para el
desarrollo económico y de las personas
de nuestro país
muy bien muchas gracias elisa walker y
es que sobre este plebiscito
constitucional en chile- ya llevamos
prácticamente una hora que se están
dando los resultados de esta jornada
histórica en la que los ciudadanos
acudieron a las urnas para decidir el
futuro de la constitución que como nos
identifican nuestras especialistas data
de 1980 cuando el poder estaba en manos
de augusto pinochet ahora hablemos sobre
las campañas previas que promovían o
rechazar una nueva carta magna o aprobar
una nueva constitución y es que estas
campañas para la jornada de hoy
estuvieron marcadas por la pandemia que
impidió el tradicional puerta a puerta
que caracteriza las elecciones en chile
les tenemos un reportaje
el mayor ruido posible a favor de la
prueba el tren de la prueba y la
caravana de motoristas parten su
recorrido en santiago en su campaña para
sumar masa de estos queremos hacer un
llamado a toda la gente de la región
metropolitana y el resto de la región
del país que voten a prueba o convención
constitucional y nos ayuden a derrocar
una constitución pinochetista llena de
sangre que ha llenado de desigualdad a
todo este país los últimos 40 años los
votantes del rechazo también se hacen
presentes javier a esa escena de una
plataforma de jóvenes llamada no gracias
que prefieren optar por reformar la
actual constitución de 1980 está idea de
una nueva constitución nos están
vendiendo la pomada que en chile
significa un poco
no están vendiendo el gato por liebre
que eso significa en definitiva de que
no están prometiendo una cosa que en
definitiva no va a ser tal
javiera es una de las jóvenes que
aparece en la famosa franja electoral
que se repite dos veces en la televisión
durante los 28 días previos a la
elección y que juega un rol importante
en los indecisos el apruebo es
mayoritario las encuestas y esto es lo
que nos cuenta la calle prueba
en el cual considero yo que debe haber
un cambio fundamental de raíces en el
sistema que no está gobernando
actualmente apruebo obviamente voy a
votar por el aprueba por a prueba
voy a votar rechazo porque creo que no
es una propuesta clara creo que
realmente el cambio de constitución fue
impulsado por grupos violentistas y creo
que porque es tirarse a la piscina sin
que haya agua adentro la nueva
constitución fue uno de los mayores
reclamos del estallido del 18 de octubre
del año pasado en el país
por eso la otra campaña se realiza en
los muros de las calles donde la prueba
también es mayoritario el domingo
sabremos si los chilenos deciden contar
por primera vez en sus más de dos siglos
de historia con una constitución elegida
por el pueblo
[Música]
momento de actualizar los resultados de
esta jornada histórica en chile- y es
que la tendencia ya es irreversible en
ambas preguntas más del 90% de
resultados al momento dejan 78,24
respondiendo que sí que si se cambie la
carta magna- 21 76% rechazo a una nueva
constitución la segunda pregunta sobre
qué órgano sería el responsable una
convención mixta 20 76% una convención
constitucional 79,24 por ciento mesas
escrutadas 90 puntos 78 es decir que del
10% restante así sea una tendencia
totalmente contraria y es irreversible
podemos afirmar que tanto la respuesta
oficial la pregunta número uno es si se
aprueba la constitución el cambio a la
carta magna- chilena y que sería
mediante una convención constitucional
regresó con nuestra corresponsal de
france 24
en la capital en santiago patricia luna
patricia como ves estos resultados y
también vamos introduciendo el siguiente
tema y es que a pesar de la insistencia
ciudadana las reformas constitucionales
chilenas han sido por presiones
militares esta va a ser la primera vez
desde 1833 que la carta magna será
redactada por una convención ciudadana
elegida en votación popular que
preocupaba a los opositores de cambiar
la constitución y cuáles son tus
impresiones al momento
bueno la verdad es que en cuanto a los
resultados será un poco la crónica de
una cuenta un poco anunciada exactamente
lo que vaticina más las encuestas uno
siempre tiene dudas que si las encuestas
están adecuadas o no de sí a veces nos
muestran los resultados que realmente
manifiesta la calle pero como decía
antes cuando he conversado con personas
en la calle muchísimas personas de todo
tipo de edad de distintas rangos
sociales se manifestaban a favor de la
prueba y también a favor de una
convención constitucional había debate
sobre si se iba a manifestar de una
forma tan contundente y ha sido muy
contundente de las calles lo están
celebrando desde hace bastante tiempo es
así como tú bien dices y le ha tenido
varias sustituciones esta sería la
puerta
ninguna de ellas anteriormente había
sido escrita y elegida por el pueblo de
la posición
la posición del actual gobierno se ha
manifestado siempre a favor de la prueba
de forma fragmentada en distintos
comandos que estuvieron trabajando por
obtener este resultado pero mientras que
en el bando del rechazo veíamos una
postura más bien unitaria comandos que
participaban de forma al unísono en los
comandos por el apruebo eran muchos eran
muy diversos pertenecían a
organizaciones sociales distintas a
partidos de ideas políticas eran
conglomerados y había muchísimos tipos
de organizaciones de forma dispersa aquí
y allá que se manifestaban a favor de es
que apruebo y de este cambio es un poco
la situación que se vive en el país
donde la oposición se encuentra muy
fragmentada en estos momentos como ha
quedado de manifiesto en los últimos
actos de hecho no fueron capaces ni
siquiera de tomar una foto a todos
unidos y de presentar una
una propuesta unidad de cara a las
presidenciales así que bueno eso es un
poco la situación en el momento hoy
patricia pareciera como si la selección
chilena estuviera ganando partidos en el
mundial ahí en las calles no mucho
festejo escuchamos los votantes
respondieron las dos preguntas patricia
sí sí comentabas
sí yo creo que es exactamente lo mismo
es como si la selección chilena hubiera
ganado un gran partido de fútbol lo que
se vive en las calles hoy y desde hace
mucho rato creo que es una gran fiesta
que para muchas personas llevaban
muchísimo tiempo tratando de celebrar
este momento es sin duda histórico y en
el que se vive las calles
de esta oposición puede dudar sobre la
legitimidad de la votación es que por
ejemplo en la segunda pregunta 1 a pesar
de decir no no quiero que se cambie la
constitución podía opinar en la segunda
pregunta bueno pero si se cambia
prefiero que sea por este órgano y
algunos opositores tú nos identificadas
podrían cuestionar la legitimidad
legislativa de esta consulta que que
podrían responder a esta oposición
bueno la verdad es que este fue un
proceso bastante pensado en el sentido
de que tuvo que ser pospuesto estaba
preparado para abril
pues curso hasta el mes de octubre y un
poco
los procedimientos también han sido
votados en el congreso por parte de
todos o sea como se iba a realizar cómo
iba a realizarse el plebiscito el
momento tuvo que ser votado por el
congreso el referente de un mismo tuvo
que ser votado con él por el congreso
porque no era posible de otra manera así
que es verdad que se le p
existían dos papeletas y eso puede
generar ciertas dudas pero por el
momento al menos yo no he escuchado
ningún comentario que ponga en duda un
poco la legitimidad de este proceso
porque en general los procesos
electorales chilenos tienen a
representantes de todos los partidos de
las mesas electorales se discuten los
resultados suelen ser muy transparentes
los resultados aparecen rápidos y no
suele haber en general cuestionamientos
o por lo menos no que tengamos
conocimiento
sobre este punto
identificas patricia era más importante
que fuera contundente las respuestas no
más que el proceso en sí que ya estaba
ampliamente aprobado vamos a ver
precisamente el desarrollo de estas
contundentes decisiones que tomaron los
chilenos tenemos nuevamente resultados
un avance al momento ya falta menos de
10 por ciento del escrutinio de las
mesas escrutadas estamos escuchando a la
autoridad electoral el detalle de los
resultados del plebiscito nacional 2020
desagregado hasta el nivel de mesa
receptora de sufragios queda a
disposición de la ciudadanía medios de
comunicación y los partidos políticos en
el sitio internet www xerv el elecciones
punto cl
muy buenas noches
vamos a ver los resultados que tenemos
entonces de estas históricas votaciones
en chile el plebiscito 2020 mesas
escrutadas 93 77 por ciento de los que
78 25 aprueban contundentemente que se
cambie la constitución chilena 21 75 por
ciento dice no a este cambio a la carta
magna- 20 78 por ciento dice que se haga
mediante una convención mixta también
más contundente incluso que los chilenos
que pedían un cambio a la constitución
es todavía más contundente la forma
buscan que sean una convención
constitucional precisamente vamos a
abordar este tema las preocupaciones que
genera pues este nuevo órgano que se
implementará para redactar una nueva
carta magna
ahora ya inminente vamos a hablar de lo
que se viene para cerrar el tema de los
temores que tenían los opositores
algunos conservadores derechistas de que
se modificara la constitución señalaban
por ejemplo empiezo con usted abogada
ponce de léon el caso venezolano donde
se ha reformado la constitución con
efectos negativos para el país qué
opinión le merece la opinión el
cuestionamiento opositor de cambiar la
constitución chilena
yo creo que siempre hay temores cuando
uno se enfrenta a un proceso nuevo
obviamente ahí surgen voces temerosas no
es cierto de que esa amplitud de
representación que puede haber en la
convención constitucional pudiera estar
no es cierto
motivada por un cambio tan radical en el
sistema concierto chileno de gobierno y
lo que era representado no es cierto
nuestra tradición que pudiera no es
cierto estar abogando por un estado
socialista no social de derecho como el
que todos aspiramos a tener si no que
derivará más en el sistema socialismo
nos estoy que no ha resultado en ninguna
parte lo sentó de una manera exitosa y
que por lo mal y por lo tanto hubiésemos
retrocedido o no ser todo perdido todos
los años de esfuerzo y que no solamente
un esfuerzo de pocos sino que de muchos
hacia llegar a un país como el que
tenemos que era el modelo como bien
decía tú
en materias relevantes
y obviamente el temor es ese pero yo
creo que el temor que se te muere es
infundado
de partida en la formación de esta
convención constitucional de 155 lo
cierto personas representantes que van a
ser votados en el 11 de abril del
próximo año van a participar en ello los
mismos conglomerados políticos son los
partidos políticos los que van a llevar
por lo menos la delantera en cuanto a
los candidatos todavía está por verse si
los independientes van a tener
precisamente una fórmula mucho más fácil
no es cierto de llegar a ser un
candidato pero se espera por lo menos
que los independientes puedan ir
asociados a las listas de los partidos
políticos que los partidos políticos en
definitiva lleven a independientes
también que de alguna manera representen
todos esos valores y eso ese espíritu de
bondad que nosotros necesitamos y de
equilibrios que nosotros necesitamos
para concierto en empezar
dar un nuevo texto constitucional yo
creo que entonces los temores existen
son son entendibles pero yo no les daría
mayor un cierto relevancia porque en
definitiva como les digo yo confío en
que van a ser las fuerzas políticas que
ya están presentes en nuestro congreso
lo que van a dotar al país también de
esos esos candidatos en definitiva yo no
creo que haya muchas caras nuevas
eso también podrías resultar buena
desazón
sí sí abogada cuántas generaciones
tendrán que pasar para despegar a chile
de la dictadura de augusto pinochet
yo creo que debiéramos no sé no podría
responder a esa pregunta porque claro es
un tema que divide al país
se vivió muy fuerte evidentemente pero
yo creo que la mayoría hoy día del país
está pensando en el futuro no podemos
estar forjando una sociedad por un
momento histórico que fue absolutamente
cierto duro en muchos aspectos pero no
yo creo que debiéramos saltar dar un
salto en esa perspectiva y esta
constitución que como algunos dicen es
la casa de todos debiera entonces ser un
punto de partida para empezar a mirar
hacia el futuro nadie está pidiendo que
olvidemos no es cierto que pero sí que
miremos con otras con otros ojos no es
cierto con otro espíritu el futuro
porque no estamos viviendo en dictadura
hace mucho tiempo gracias a lo que no
estamos viviendo en esas situaciones por
lo tanto tenemos que forjar un país
próspero un país solidario que tanta
falta solidaridad a propósito de toda
esta desigualdad yo creo que en ese rol
también el estado tiene mucho que hacer
el estado no solamente subsidiario como
se dijo acá que nos está en un sentido
de que tiene que ir en un sentido
negativo y que tiene que atenerse cuando
las personas son capaces de forjar su
propio futuro con sus cumplir sus
derechos y sus intereses
sino que el estado también tiene que ser
fuerte en los sistemas o mecanismos de
control tiene que cambiar a lo mejor su
fórmula centralista también tiene que
tenemos que avanzar en la
descentralización como se decía aquí
también en el reconocimiento a las
minorías no sé yo creo que eso es eran
yo creo que son y no debemos estar un
cierto pensando en en el en el pasado y
obviamente las personas que se sufrieron
las consecuencias de esa dictadura
evidentemente no les va a cambiar
digamos su forma pero o su vida pero
todas maneras hay que mirar hacia
adelante creo yo bien abogado pues
todavía no me despido de usted todavía
hay una ronda última de preguntas y
quiero comentar con usted el proceso
constituyente que previo a esta emisión
usted ya me estaba identificando ahora
es momento de que vayamos con elisa
walker ella es la especialista magíster
en derecho y en filosofía abogada es
este el mejor escenario para disminuir
las tensiones y es que mire si la
diferencia hubiera sido pequeña esto
podría ser problemático mientras que si
la respuesta habría sido no en cambiar
la carta magna esa opción no contemplaba
siquiera un camino claro después un
órgano específico por ejemplo las
reformas que se hicieran en caso del
rechazo se harían a través del actual
parlamento según dicta su constitución
los cambios no tendrían entonces tanta
legitimidad como la que tendría un
órgano especialmente elegido para ello
por ello preguntó este fue el mejor
escenario que de los que pudo haber
pasado hoy para disminuir las tensiones
alan sin duda alguna este es el mejor
resultado justamente para calmar las
tensiones en las que tú haces referencia
tenemos una crisis institucional no hay
duda alguna sobre la materia pero lo
importante es que el resultado del día
lo que demuestra es que acá en chile
queremos que nuestros conflictos tengan
una respuesta institucional para que
sean resueltos y esa respuesta política
esa respuesta institucional de
conversación de diálogo de estructura de
instituciones es el resultado del
plebiscito que vivimos hoy en día porque
habían muchos algunos bueno algunos
verdad ahora que tenemos los resultados
en mano nos damos cuenta que los que
apoyaban el rechazo no eran muchos sino
que eran algunos pero algunos que
llamaban a decir no apruebe esta nueva
constitución yo rechazo para reformar yo
rechazo para reformar eso sí que era una
respuesta poco concreta y poco adecuada
a nuestra situación política compleja
porque este rechazo
para reformar era una carta sin
orientación y yo necesito realmente para
tener estabilidad institucional en
nuestro país tener una conversación
profunda entre iguales que es lo que
permite este proceso constituyente pero
que tenga un claro inicio y un claro
término entonces está creo sin duda agua
y sin lugar a duda es la respuesta más
adecuada y también quiero hacer una
referencia a la pregunta anterior que tú
le hacía a sandra sobre la dictadura que
donde harías abierta la insegura de
pinochet es una es una herida profunda
que todavía sigue vigente en nuestro
país obviamente que el proceso
constituyente y el crear una nueva
constitución va a ayudar a superar esta
experiencia traumática de lo que fue la
dictadura de pinochet pero es importante
y siempre recordar que existen deudas
todavía de verdad y de justicia en
especial a los detenidos-desaparecidos a
las familias de los
detenidos-desaparecidos nosotros hasta
el día de hoy
tenemos muchas familias que no saben
dónde mataron a sus parientes por tener
una opinión política diferente entonces
este proceso constituyente que nos
recuerda que las instituciones importan
que la democracia importa también que
los derechos humanos importan porque
esta conversación que vamos a tener
entre todos que sin duda alguna esta no
va a ser la constitución de maduro esta
no va a ser la constitución de venezuela
porque aquí necesitamos dos tercios para
probar la constitución ese es un fuero
que nos obliga a hacer un ejercicio
transversal este no va a ser el traje a
la medida para ninguna de las personas
este va a ser el resultado de un diálogo
pero ese resultado tiene que ser
adecuado y por eso se sustenta en un
proceso que es adecuado que no va a
hacer el traje la medida a ninguna de
las personas pero si hablamos de venta
dura recordemos que hay hay heridas
vigentes que todavía y creo que como
país es imposible de resistir
idea de que todavía hay personas que no
saben qué pasó con sus parientes pues
las violaciones a los derechos humanos y
ahora perdón lo que iba a decirte es que
esta constitución sea cual sea el
contenido que tengas sabemos cuál es el
piso mínimo que es el resguardo de los
derechos humanos porque en el acuerdo
político que sustenta este proceso
constituyente se estableció
explícitamente y claramente que lo que
se acuerda en esta constitución tiene
que resguardar los deberes derechos
humanos y recordando lo que fue la
dictadura creo que es importante y nos
debiera llenar de orgullo asumir que los
derechos humanos en la actualidad son
del estándar básico de comunicación y de
acuerdo político que se establezcan en
nuestro país
elisa no me despego pero ahí vienen más
resultados electorales ya están a menos
del 5% de la totalidad son 43 mil dos
mesas escrutadas de un total de 44 mil
913 es menos de un 5% insisto lo que
falta
a escrutar por contar en esta votación
histórica 78 27 aprueba el cambio a la
constitución 21 73 dicen o 20 78 20 78
perdón también dice que sería mediante
una convención mixta más contundente
todavía es una convención constitucional
es decir a personajes específicamente
ubicados para hacer esta nueva
constitución regreso contigo eliçabe
walker y es que conozco también tu gusto
regional y quiero ver si nos puedes
empapar un poquito para los otros países
latinoamericanos de ese entusiasmo que
te estamos detectando lo ocurrido hoy en
chile servirá de ejemplo para que países
con constituciones de época de dictadura
hay algunos centroamericanos por ejemplo
que generan desigualdad hagan lo mismo
este puede ser un parteaguas
para muchos este es un proceso de
esperanza entendiendo que la política es
un ejercicio de diálogo y también en
nuestra región como tú bien dices alan
tenemos historias traumáticas no sólo en
chile sino que en nuestros países
vecinos compañeros de región también y
que es lo importante es que tenemos que
recordar siempre que un país
comprometido con la democracia y que
cree en la democracia siempre tiene que
confiar
en la voz de sus ciudadanos acá no hay
una sola persona dictando las normas del
presente y del futuro acá vamos a hacer
todos los que nos vamos a sentar a
conversar ese es un ejercicio ciudadano
es un ejercicio que cree en la política
es un ejercicio de participación y para
que las instituciones sean estables yo
vuelvo que tú que plantaba tú
al principio sobre la situación
económica nosotros queremos desarrollo
en nuestro país
nosotros queremos desarrollo político
nosotros queremos desarrollo social y
también desarrollo económico y para eso
tenemos que comprometernos con nuestras
instituciones y respetarlas y
respetarlas también porque las
instituciones tienen que ser reflejo de
lo mejor de nosotros así que muchos hoy
en día estamos orgullosos del proceso
que vivimos en especial orgullosa de la
paz que se ve en las calles nosotros
tuvimos muchos chilenos y chilenas que
salieron a votar el apruebo y fue
respaldado por una amplia mayoría y lo
que vemos en este minuto en las calles
es una fiesta es esperanza y no es
violencia y yo también espero que ese
mismo espíritu se mantenga y se proyecte
en el tiempo durante este proceso
constituyente y todos esperamos
alan incluso los que votaron rechazo
obviamente los que votamos apruebas
todos esperamos que este proceso sea
exitoso porque todos queremos lo mejor
para nuestro país
muy bien igual regreso contigo para
conclusiones finales abogada elisa
walker vamos a despedir obra de patricia
luna nuestra corresponsal de france 24
en la capital en santiago que no tenemos
ahorita la imagen pero sí la tenemos vía
telefónica no sólo despedirte y conocer
tus impresiones finales
patricia sino también felicitarte por
este excelente cubrimiento que
realizaste de la jornada histórica que
vivió chile el día de hoy que se viene
ya sabemos que si se cambia la
constitución y que será un órgano
específico el responsable de hacerlo
ahora que se viene patricio
pues ahora se viene una nueva campaña
hasta abril para definir estos nuevos
constituyentes no sabemos bien quiénes
vienen van a ser que ha habido algunos
nombres que han surgido en las últimas
semanas personas que han luchado por la
diversidad sexual personas que tienen un
aún son conocidas por el público chileno
corre realizar distinto tipo de obras
sociales o de fines sociales pero va a
ser muy interesante de ver quiénes van a
ser las personas que se van a postular a
partir de ahora para elaborar esta nueva
constitución cuáles van a ser los nuevos
nombres los líderes sociales y las ideas
que se abren paso en ese nuevo texto
constitucional así que será en las
próximas elecciones en abril así que
esto es el principio de una continuación
digamos no de una historia que todavía
se tiene que escribir nunca mejor visto
ha sido una jornada muy emocionante ha
sido muy emocionante estar en chile-
estos últimos días
el ambiente la gente ver la fiesta ver
la anticipación de lo que se venía a
enterrar un poco ese pasado que venía
arrastrando como un poco como como un
lastre y ver ahora a la gente las calles
soltar ese lastre sentir como que nace
un nuevo país es un momento muy muy muy
bonito de vivir también de retransmitir
así que ha sido una forma muy
emocionante y yo creo que viste bien
muchas más emociones por el camino a las
próximas meses estaremos contando si
patricia como dice es un momento alegre
emotivo el que parece estar
identificándose ahí en la capital
chilena en santiago sin embargo también
en un contexto de pandemia ahí vemos
poco uso del cubrebocas de las
mascarillas tu amplia no si esta
información que yo detecto ahí en las
imágenes es correcta y también en un
contexto de protestas que han terminado
en violencia entonces las medidas de
seguridad también en tu última
intervención
coméntanos tanto de las precauciones que
se están tomando por la pandemia
pero también las precauciones por
seguridad ante las protestas algunas de
ellas violentas que ha vivido la capital
bueno en las últimas semanas en la
última semana aproximadamente hemos
visto una nueva táctica desplegada por
la policía en lo que es flash e italia
que implica dejar un poco a los
manifestantes que se manifiesten sin
intervenir y eso ha generado bueno que
haya habido violencia pero fiscal menos
violencia de la que hemos visto
habitualmente en los meses pasados en
cuanto a la pandemia todas las personas
en las que yo estoy viendo caminar en
este momento llevan la mascarilla no sé
si ese es el caso en la plaza donde hay
un mayor cúmulo de gente y hay menos
distancia social las personas que vemos
ahora en las calles todas llevan
mascarillas y hoy durante la votación sí
que se trató de guardar un poco las
normas básicas aunque no siempre se
respetó la distancia social a veces por
la cantidad de gente que había en las
colas pero todo el mundo sí que porta
mascarilla así que se va con su alcohol
o gel así que bueno veamos a ver si en
las próximas semanas esto tiene un
impacto en el número de casos que hay de
coronavirus que en el país que de hace
poco sobrepasó el medio millón
eso sería un poco la violencia hoy por
lo menos hasta el momento la celebración
es pacífica no en la zona en donde
nosotros estamos no y no se no se
percibe más que una celebración alegre
de gente celebrando y por el momento no
haya no hay actos de violencia pero como
se vio la semana pasada es una mezcla
que siempre puede arder y en que habrá
que medir ahora de cerca también no se
abre un nuevo proceso y esperemos que
esto también calme un poquito las aguas
en ese sentido muy bien patricia luna
muchas gracias muchas felicidades de
nuevo por este excelente cubrimiento que
nos hiciste durante la jornada de hoy y
ahora finalizó su pregunta de sandra
ponce león lo prometido es deuda sandra
nada más que ahora te voy a quedar a
deber en el tiempo nos queda sólo un
minuto para cada una de ustedes háblanos
de ese proceso constituyente que se
acordó por la reforma constitucional de
diciembre de 2019
y que señala que tener un texto
constitucional debe ser más acorde con
las demandas sociales un minutito si
mira efectivamente se fusionan de
acuerdo todos los parlamentarios no es
cierto para llevar adelante la reforma
en diciembre y que permitía no es cierto
desarrollar de pues de manera
transparente de manera muy eficiente
como lo ha sido este proceso
constituyente
ahora viene como decía no es cierto la
presentación de las candidaturas y el
registro de las candidaturas en el
servicio electoral para quienes deseen
formar parte de esta convención
constitucional y eso hacer es después en
abril la elección y luego cuando ya
estén electos el presidente de la
república los va a convocar para junio
empezar a funcionar por el plazo de
nueve meses más tres meses si es que
necesitan lo cierto de esa prórroga y
luego va a haber un plebiscito que se
denomina de salida nada de término en
donde las personas de nuevo van a votar
si quieren o no
y aceptan o no ese texto que les va a
proponer la convención muy bien abogada
ponce de león finalizó contigo elisa
walker que se viene ya nos hablaban de
una nueva campaña un segundo referendo
tú eres la especialista te escuchamos
efectivamente como bien decía sangre
ahora bien las candidaturas de los
constituyentes después la discusión
formal en el proceso constituyente
finalmente el plebiscito de salida pero
lo que yo quiero resaltar es que no sólo
desde ahora sino que desde hace varios
años atrás en nuestro país tenemos una
conversación y no digo una discusión
sino que es una conversación sobre el
contenido de la nueva constitución y eso
ya está en desarrollo y eso va a seguir
y va a ser paralelo a lo que son las
elecciones y tiene que tener un diálogo
nutritivo con el trabajo que va a hacer
la convención constitucional acá vive
una demanda ciudadana de participación y
la solicitud de hacer una nueva
constitución en gran parte viene por la
demanda ciudadana por lo mismo esta
convención constitucional que va a ser
100% elegida por todos los que tenemos
derecho a voto no puede aislarse no
puede dejar de escuchar a la ciudadanía
sino que ahora
el puente de conversación de escuchar
alargó a lo largo de chile de norte a
sur y generar puentes de comunicación
porque la constitución tiene que ser la
representación de todos los diálogos que
se están desarrollando bien pues muchas
gracias elisa walker aprovecho para
agradeceros rápidamente a nuestras
invitadas a la corresponsal de en
santiago patricia luna y también a elisa
walker abogada magíster en derecho y
filosofía y a sandra ponce de léon
abogada magíster en derecho público hoy
chile decidió cambiar la constitución y
que sea mediante una convención
constitucional
gracias siga con nosotros en france 24
[Música]